[Musik]
herzlich willkommen am
truppenübungsplatz mal wiesen in kärnten
mein name ist oliver ich bin da zugs
kommandant des kampfmittel abwehr zu
gast in der kampf unterstützungs
kompanie beim pioneer batteln 1 unsere
aufträge umfassen nicht nur die
unterstützung der polizei im inland
sondern auch blindgänger suchen auf
unseren truppenübungsplätzen weitere
aufgaben sind die unterstützung bzw den
truppen schutz im auslandseinsatz am
balkan heute möchte ich unseren verlinkt
manipulator theodor präsentieren das ist
eine abkürzung heißt thiele rob
explosive ordnance disposal observation
roboter wir setzen diesen roboter in
unseren einsätzen zur terroristischen
abwehr ein der roller da besteht aus
zwei komponenten den roboter selbst und
den beginn stand zu den technischen
daten die technischen daten des roboters
er ist 120 cm lang 70 cm breit und hat
ein gewicht von 360 kilogramm mit den
akkus die hauptkomponenten des roboters
sind der die wanne mit denkt mit den
ketten laufwerk und den drehbaren turm
im navara befinden sich die akkus und
die elektronik im heck des roboters
angebracht befindet sich noch ein waffen
halter und eine trommel mit einem
lichtwellenleiter
zum turm der turm besteht besteht einmal
aus seinen oberarm einen unterarm und
einen drehbaren teil es sind hier
mehrere kameras angebracht wir haben
hier eine schulter kamera wir haben eine
kamera zum rückwärtsfahren mir meine
kamera im vorderen bereich zum vorwärts
fahren und wir haben hinten eine
ausfahrbare turm kamera vorgänger gerät
erkennen unsere waffen halter und der
demontiert werden als erstes ein kabel
schneider
eine elektrische flex und
ein akkubohrer
ein weiteres zubehör für uns ein roboter
ist das röntgen system das ramp r system
besteht aus einem rundgang generator und
einem image der die bilder generiert die
wir dann auf unseren laptops auswerten
können
folgende waffensysteme können am
verlinkt manipulator theodor montiert
werden hier am unterarm sehen wir dass
12,7 millimeter gadget long folgende
medien können damit verschossen werden
ein tornister mit stahlkugeln mit einem
flachen kopf und einen mitteln spitzen
kopf
weiters können wir wasser verschießen
die einsatzleiter des waffensystems
beträgt sieben bis zehn meter ich mal
zum tönen für den ich zünde
weiter
verwenden wir beim theodor der das
delitzscher
12,7 millimeter
die beiden waffensysteme werden
verwendet im terror einsatz wir schießen
auf distanzen auf improvisierte sprechen
und fahren brandvorrichtungen um diese
elektronischen schaltungen im id zu
trennen
weiters kann man am waffen halter
seitlich am unterarm vom terror die
benelli shotgun montieren 12,7
millimeter
diese waffe wird verwendet um fenster
bei autos oder
häusern durch schloss herauszuschießen
sollte es die lage nicht mehr zulassen
dass wir unsere fern denkt manipulator
theodor einsetzen können haben wir einen
schweren bomben schutzanzug dieser
schwere bomben schutzanzug wird durch
einen spezialisten des
kampfmittelräumdienstes
daten dieser bomben schutzanzug ist von
der firma garant heißt sps 15 und ist
ungefähr 40 kilogramm schwer der helm
hat ein gewicht von zwölf kilogramm der
hauptsitz des anzuges befindet sich im
vorderen bereich hier befindet sich eine
panzerplatte drinnen der restliche teil
des anzuges besteht dass seine aramid
faser gegen was schützt dieser anzug
dieser anzug schutz gegen splitter
gegendruck gegen feuer
[Musik]
wenn ihr interesse habt in unserem team
mitzuarbeiten in der beschreibung unten
findet ihr unsere kontaktdaten in diesem
sinne möchte ich mich mit theodor bei
euch mit einem pioniere wie immer
verabschieden